movies are a visual medium and therefore
most movies major characters are well
visible to the audience but as with any
rule there are notable exceptions and to
prove it these are just a few memorable
examples of film characters you never
see thanks to the success of the
original Charlie's Angels television
series which ran from 1976 to 1981 a
film reboot was inevitable in 2000
director Mick G's adaptation which
starred Cameron Diaz Drew Barrymore and
Lucy Liu hit theaters as the titular
team working out of an exclusive agency
in Los Angeles
the trio lent the film the feel of the
original television series while setting
it in a more modern era and stretching
one mystery into a longer story as in
the original series Charlie is
perpetually unseen accessible only
through speaker and identified only as
the angels millionaire boss who finds
them different jobs gives them
instructions and works through his
assistant Bosley though the film never
addresses why Charlie isn't present
aside from indicating that he's
frequently targeted by villains and
assassins the closing scene shows a man
quietly observing the angels who could
be Charlie himself though he remains
obscured to the viewer it's called Spike
Jones is known for his inventive and
vicious projects and 2013's her which
won Best Original Screenplay at the 86th
Academy Awards as well as scoring a
nomination for Best Picture tackles the
concept of artificial intelligence from
an entirely new perspective set just
slightly ahead of the present day the
film imagines a time when humans are
able to create virtual assistants using
artificial intelligence
Theodore played by Joaquin Phoenix feels
disconnected from the people around him
after a rough divorce until he meets
Samantha I can understand how the
limited perspective of an artificial
mind would perceive it that way you'll
get used to it as Theodore gets closer
to his AI assistant Samantha seductively
voiced by Scarlett Johansson he realizes
that the relationship isn't as special
as he previously thought she admits that
she's in similar relationships and in
love with hundreds of other people
before telling him that she and the
other AIS are leaving the human sphere
as
he creeps closer to the advent of new
forms of artificial intelligence the
unseen assistance of her become even
more relevant warning audiences about
the benefits and costs of technology
that may soon become a reality
adapted from Ira Levin's novel Roman
Polanski's horror classic Rosemary's
Baby stars Mia Farrow as rosemary a
woman who believes a satanic cult wants
to use her baby for evil purposes
when rosemary and her husband guy move
into their new apartment in New York
City they befriend an odd elderly couple
who welcomes the young pair with open
arms however throughout the film
rosemary becomes suspicious of them and
as she experiences the truly horrific
pregnancy she realizes that her child is
not her husband's but actually the son
of the devil and she must raise the
child as her own to appease this
dangerous cult what they do Guy they use
blood in their rituals and the blood
that has the most power as baby's blood
during the film's finale
rosemary discovers that her child is the
son of Satan who chose her to carry his
baby and rather than show the baby
directly there's simply a flash of a
demonic face perhaps the child's father
Satan he has his father's eyes
in refusing to show an actual shot of
the child
the film leaves its appearance up to the
imagination making it even more
frightening than say a potentially
unrealistic prosthetic demon baby the
second film in the long-running earnest
film series Ernest saves Christmas
features Jim Barney's character Ernest
and serves as the holiday-themed
installment in the franchise Ernest who
appeared in several commercials for
brands like coca-cola and Chex made his
mark by always delivering an impassioned
off-topic monologue to his friend Vern
while speaking directly to the camera
which always culminated in him
proclaiming the virtues of whatever
product he happened to be pitching gotta
burn another pacific building that's a
keeper in Ernest saves Christmas Ernest
a taxi driver working in Florida
inadvertently picks up Santa Claus and
accidentally gains possession of Santa's
magic sack of toys through a series of
misadventures he helps find the next man
who will become Santa Claus and make
sure Christmas go smoothly and also
throughout the film he delivers his
trademark monologues to Vern whose POV
is once again provided by the camera
during one notable scene he even helps
host a Christmas party at burns house
much to Verne's apparent chagrin I
thought you said this Vern was a friend
ears no verbs just like that he'll do
anything burlap okay so chances are you
already know the whole story of Romeo
and Juliet from forth the fatal loins of
these two foes a pair of star-crossed
lovers take their life but in case
you've been living under a rock here
goes
Romeo and Juliet respective heirs to the
warring Montague and Capulet families
meet by chance at a party and
immediately fall in love even though
they're conditioned to hate one another
and even though Juliet is already
engaged to someone else though they do
their best to make a new life together
their plans are foiled at every turn and
they eventually do the whole poison /
dagger thing and yadda yadda yadda you
know how this one turns out poison
kiss thy lips a please some poison dust
yeah hang on him ah crap wrong movie
hold tight the play has seen plenty of
adaptations over the years but the most
popular among modern viewers is Baz
Luhrmann's fantastical Romeo and Juliet
which modernizes the set and costumes
while retaining the original prose it's
pretty weird and it shouldn't work but
honestly somehow it does they've made
worms meat of me
they'll most know the narrative outline
it's easy to forget that Juliet isn't
always the only girl on Romeo's mind in
fact when the story begins Romeo is
heartsick over another girl Rosalyn who
seemingly won't give him the time of day
when his friend Mercutio encourages him
to attend Juliet's party so he can
forget about Rosalyn Romeo's former love
is forgotten and in fact never appears
in the play or film at all
still she plays a relatively important
part in the whole tragic mess if she
hadn't left Romeo heartbroken he may
never have even met Juliet
2010's Winter's Bone introduced Jennifer
Lawrence to mainstream film audiences
set in the Ozarks this low-budget drama
stars Lawrence as Reid who is solely
responsible for taking care of her
mentally ill mother as well as her two
younger siblings while she attempts to
teach her siblings how to survive she's
also tasked with finding her father who
has disappeared after his arrest for
making meth and the stakes are high if
she doesn't find him in time then her
family's house and land will be seized
leaving them with a week to find
somewhere else to live along the way she
runs afoul of the town's crime boss
Milton while everyone tells her that her
father is already dead and she tries to
figure out what the real story is even
as bondsmen hunt him down some of our
blood at least is the same ain't that
supposed to mean something and that what
has always said as it turns out everyone
is right her father is in fact dead as
rediscovers when the Milton clan shows
her his body partially submerged in a
lake left only with his hands to
identify him to the sheriff and bondsman
Gries journey is over and she can be at
peace but her unseen father's character
remains vital to the story as searching
for him to save her family is what
drives her throughout the entire
narrative the 1964 classic dr.
Strangelove or how I learned to stop
worrying and love the bomb sprung from
the mind of legendary director Stanley
Kubrick this dark comedy focuses on a
cold war-era nuclear conflict between
the United States and the Soviet Union
stirring legends Peter Sellers and
George C Scott the film's central
conflict hinges upon a deranged general
who orders a nuclear strike by the
United States against the Soviet Union
and the efforts of the United States
president and his cabinet to then try
and stop the strike though this might
not sound like a laugh riot the script
and sellers multiple performances are so
Arius that the film has become known as
one of cinema's best comedies earning
itself a place in the National Film
registry and a third spot on the 100
years100 last list at AFI because the
film centers on a conflict between the
US and Soviet Union one might think the
Russian premier would be fairly central
but thanks to the focus on the United
States government's response premier
Dmitri kiss-off is ultimately never seen
providing most of the film's push and
pull without ever having to physically
appear on screen and existing only
through phone calls to and from the
president oh we're doing a documentary
about the Blair Witch Oh have you heard
of the Blair Witch one of the first
forays into the modern era of the
found-footage sub-genre of horror films
that Blair Witch Project was filmed over
only eight days stranding actors in the
woods with handheld equipment to lend an
air of authenticity to the frightening
story not playing head games and if
anyone's playing head games you're
playing head games but I'm not playing
head games
in fact the viral marketing campaign was
almost too successful including the
decision to keep the actors from
attending the film's premiere and
listing them as deceased on IMDB the
production was a real-life horror in its
own right the actors were intentionally
deprived of food and pranked by the crew
to elicit real reactions for the final
product in the low-budget high scares
flick a group of amateur filmmakers
Heather Mike and Josh document their
search for the mysterious Blair Witch
though they're initially skeptical of
any supernatural phenomena during their
time in the woods they're tormented by
some unseen force when Josh goes missing
it appears as if the Blair Witch herself
is mimicking his screams to lure
heatherandmike after they find an
abandoned house
Mike's camera footage ends and Heather
finds him silently standing in a corner
just before she's attacked herself as
the film progresses it becomes clear why
the Blair Witch is never seen it's
simply far scarier that
based on the 1944 Pulitzer winning stage
play of the same name by Mary chase the
1950 film Harvey Stars James Stewart and
Josephine hull and tells a rather
unconventional tale Stewart plays Elwood
P Dowd a cheerful friendly lush with one
very unique characteristic his best
friend is a six foot tall invisible
rabbit named Harvey though Elwood's
family including his sister and niece
are exasperated and concerned by
Elwood's imaginary friend his appealing
leave pleasant demeanor leads to Elwood
making friends at his neighborhood bar
where the bartender always greets Harvey
and serves Elwood two martinis naturally
if the absence of the film's title
character is what drives the entire
story as Elwood's family fearing for his
well-being and sanity has him committed
to an institution to help potentially
cure him however over time Elwood's
doctor dr. Chumley begins to believe
Elwood and believe in Harvey first dr.
Chumley seemed little frightened to
party but that gave way to admiration as
the evening wore in the end of woods
loved one save him from a medicine that
would make him normal and stop him from
seeing his beloved bunny bestie the film
was incredibly well reviewed leaving a
lasting lesson that imagination is not a
flaw but something that can bring real
joy to anyone if they'd only believed
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]